hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is tamara has never seen and
today I'm watching Freddy got fingered I
was just in the nostalgia critic review
of Freddy got fingered and purposefully
did not watch the review yet squids
identity we did some No Country for Old
Men parodies in that review I also have
nothing that shocked today I'm in a very
glam early 2000s look because Freddy got
fingered came out in 2001 and I needed
something fun to do because this is
gonna be a mess I think I don't actually
know I said I was gonna do it online and
everyone was like no save yourself no
stay with Robert Rock but there's quite
a few people have talked to you in real
life about the film who say that they
remember it being funny and that they
remember like enjoying it I have no
recollection of Tom green that's
probably because I didn't watch I almost
said MySpace I wasn't allowed to watch
myspace is a good I didn't watch MTV or
like vh1 or whatever show he was on
Comedy Central I didn't watch any of
that stuff growing up I wasn't allowed
to and so I don't have any recollection
of knowing him I don't think I ever saw
anything he was ever in kind of look
like one of the princesses and Candyland
that wasn't my intention but here we are
all right sausage
let's do it
[Music]
what in the actual
what's that in acting school they tell
you to follow your impulse it's an actor
if you just follow your impulse
you'll never be led astray this guy took
that note and just ran with it he's like
oh yeah you want me to follow my impulse
well how would I jack off a horse
spoilers there's entirely too much
animal jacking off way too many hand
jobs for animals that's my first thing
that should be a shirt Freddy got
fingered way too many hand jobs for
animals in Tamara's opinion it's a long
chair but it's it needs to be made
please don't make that sure this story
is about this man child's named gourd
which a terrible name gourd I'm sorry if
that's your name but gourd is this
manchild baby who is 28 years old what's
everyone know it and he can't keep a job
he's suffering from some major mental
issues clearly and isn't able to hold
down a job because he wants to be an
animator he achieves that dream to a
certain extent through some weird
loopholes with his dad and then he
jacked off an elephant on his dad and
and then that's pretty much it
you know that's I mean that's basically
the movie it opens on x-ray cat and I
really liked x-ray cat I thought that
was funny and then you see this banana
character who gets a job I'm like hell
yeah good for him
I enjoyed that I liked the animations
that this guy did I wasn't hating inks I
had built up such like a scared miss of
this film when cuz I was ready for it I
legitimately said that I might actually
be okay with this movie and then he
jacked off a horse I'm super I needed I
No you've heard of horse girls but have
you heard of horse boys no I'm just
gonna insert that no every time
something really terrible happens then
it just goes from weird scene to weird
seemed weird seemed weird scene and
that's obviously what the movie is so
you go into his cheese sandwich factory
job and he gets tired of having a cheese
sandwich factory job even though it's
been like two seconds and so he like
climbs on the conveyor belt has a
sausage in his hands and then like
shedding it's his penis and he's like
Irish sexy boy I'm a sexy boy equal one
a you're not to be stopped that it's
unsanitary
3-seat are their sandwich cheese
factories then he needs drew Barrymore
in the film and she calls him a skinny
loser who needs to stop well that was
the only line in the whole film that
made any sense also inconceivable to me
that he was married to her crazy that
he's a nice guy
I shouldn't be sick so Gord is in and
he's talking to the animator of God and
he's trying to get a job from and the
guy literally says to him there has to
be something that happens that is
actually funny it's a literal line in
the movie is that like meta did he do
that on purpose or is that just sad
probably both the animator tells him
that if he's going to be drawing animals
he has to get inside of the animals and
so of course in the very next shot he
drives up to a dead deer in the middle
of the road and I just said don't that
deer don't that deer don't he doesn't
video and it's somehow worse
go ahead insert it insert it now
No then he drives by the horses again
going back home he decides he doesn't
want to live in Hollywood it's too hard
and the horses are fought and he starts
eating sandwiches really fast and
messily and I don't understand the scene
is he turned on by it or is he upset by
it
are they not related what's happening
here what is going on it started
no his friend breaks his leg with really
bad practical effects and he licks his
open wound his bone is sticking out his
leg and he licks it so wacky then he's
in the hospital for his friend and the
woman next to then the hospital bed over
is having a child and he delivers the
child and it also feels like people
aren't gonna like that I use this word
but it feels like Mary were like right
be like she's like please get a doctor
and he's like no I'm the doctor I'll do
it and like starts grabbing in her
vagina and it just feels like it's a lot
it's like a horrific scene to watch then
the baby isn't crying everyone's like
okay well they're making a dead baby
joke
so 2001 of them and then he starts
swinging the baby by its umbilical cord
and then the baby starts crying and then
later he tapes the umbilical cord on his
stomach for some reason cuz he's so
wacky
so he meets somebody at the hospital
though they start dating she gives him a
lot of blowjobs then they go on a second
date and he tells her he doesn't want a
blowjob
he wants to like just hang out and get
to know where one feels very out of
character for this character also you
didn't ask the horse a big one with a
hand job but the elephant later if it
wanted the hand job did you know you
just went in for it I don't even have
the energy to talk about this messages
oh and then boorda tells the therapist
that his dad has been fingering freddie
that's all going with for the title of
okay Tom Green though is like this
chaotic neutral
he's not like chaotic good by any means
he's also just not chaotic evil he's
just kind of himself and like he causes
havoc around him but it's just like his
own thing I got a bag of jewels for you
Betty I don't want a bag of jewels Gord
I just want to suck your cock okay
that's a little funny so he spends all
of his money on Jules a helicopter
rental and moving at heart of his
parents house to Pakistan to prank his
dad prank yeah and then he jerks off an
elephant and that's just I mean that's
basically the end of the movie oh but
then at the very end the mom is with
Shaq the mom left the death is with Shaq
best part of the film for me by far I'm
gonna watch the desalter critic review
of it a real quick BRB
yep same a lot of things about how I'm
gonna cry a lot of things about how
people are sorry for me people telling
me not to do it it's not confession this
is one of my guilty pleasure films I
know plot my stuff the characters are
silly the mums like you have to have
cheese in a cheese sandwich and look at
me daddy I'm a farmer just really make
me laugh and you know what I can't fault
you for having this guilty pleasure I
even hate the concept of guilty pleasure
movies enjoy what you're gonna enjoy one
100% though I have to question you
though
with the whole look at me daddy I'm a
farmer really is it the line that makes
you laugh or is it is it is it jacking
off a horse what do you think Tom Green
live howl tamo react to Freddy got
fingered what do you think no the best
way to watch Brady got fingered is to
take it out of the Machine and break the
disc into unfortunately I watched this
on Amazon Prime I'm gonna see y'all next
week with the last starfighter back Oh
hand flips no no this movie doesn't
deserve hair flips okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you